Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
all about how loki and kang just set up everything
that's going to be happening during marvel phase
4 and the movies and the disney plus series like
marvel's what if everything is connected there's
going to be a bunch of really cool easter eggs
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i will be
doing videos for all the what-if episodes it's
going to start in a couple weeks on august 11th
it'll be a wednesday show just like loki so
it'll be the exact same video schedule that i had
for my loki videos and careful for spoilers for
everything that happened on the loki series if you
have not seen those episodes yet because a lot of
what's happening is based on what happened at the
end of loki episode 6. but during the loki finale
kang revealed his grand plan and the gambit for
loki and sylvie kill him stop his current system
of using the tva to control the single sacred
timeline that we've known is the main mcu timeline
for all the marvel movies so far or take his place
and run the tva themselves and keep the system
going revealing that as bad as it was that he was
erasing all these other alternate timelines for
seemingly small reasons he was in fact stopping
alternate timelines from being created wherein
variants of himself dangerous variants would
rise up like evil versions of kang because that
would lead to another all-out multiverse kang war
and threaten to destroy all of reality the
entire multiverse as we know it silvi killed
him not because she wanted a multiverse war but
because she didn't believe what he was saying
turns out he was telling the truth oops and
as we see the sacred timeline branch out into
hundreds then thousands of alternate timelines
alternate realities the infinite kang variants
start rising up and the multiverse war starts
playing out again killing he who remains kang
also reset the timeline so that everything in
the main mcu timeline that we've seen so far
restarts the reason it did that was just because
of the way he was manipulating the timeline
to keep it in a loop state it just made it easier
to control all of time simultaneously that way but
now marvel's using each of these new branches that
you see growing these branch timelines as a way to
explain all the new mcu multiverse of the movies
and the shows like this is a branch where the sony
spider-man movies with toby maguire took place
here's a branch representing the universe where
the amazing spider-man andrew garfield movies
took place here's another branch representing
the marvel netflix universe here's one for the
deadpool movies another one for the fox movies
and so on and so forth you get the idea and
now it makes more sense why marvel waited to
release the what if episodes till now because
they're using loki to set up most of the major
twists of the next several years of the marvel
movies and disney plus series like spiderman
no way home for instance this is probably one
of the best reasons why sony has not released
the spiderman no way home trailer yet after
you watch the loki finale now it'll make more
sense when a bunch of characters from the tobey
maguire and andrew garfield's spiderman movies
start appearing in the main mcu universe with
tom holland spider-man oh it's the kang war it's
happening across the multiverse whole universes
are being deleted in mass doctor strange is trying
to salvage what he can in these sinister six toby
mcguire characters andrew garfield characters have
no way home right now just like sylvie had no way
home because her timeline was deleted there was a
rumor a long time ago that the title of spider-man
no way home was a reference to the villains the
multiverse sinister six characters having no way
home and now that makes a little more sense the
marvel what if episodes are just a different spin
on that concept you all probably noticed in the
last big what if trailer they focus very heavily
on the footage that mirrored the creation of the
original avengers team through marvel phase one
two and three a lot of the scenes were from the
early marvel phase one movies just flipped on
their head like what if iron man didn't become
iron man what if he was saved by killmonger
and what if killmonger became black panther
what if skinny boy steve rogers became howard
stark's version of iron man during world war
ii and peggy carter got the super soldier serum
becoming captain britain the reason why she's got
this british uniform the british flag on her
shield is because she was part of the british
army when she was working on the super soldier
project but i believe they're just calling her
captain carter during the series like that's what
it'll say on all of her toys we see a new version
of the doctor strange origin story where he goes
super dark and the events of the first thor movie
play out differently thor gets his hammer back
without learning his lesson seems like and winds
up turning into an even bigger party animal i
believe that's why they're calling him party
thor during the series and then they legit show
us that avengers assemble moment from the first
avengers movie but suddenly it's different and
you have all these different characters becoming a
different version of the team even though they're
the multiverse avengers i believe the name that
they're using on the show just to differentiate it
is the guardians of the multiverse but it's a lot
like marvel's exiles if you're a big comic book
fan but the idea in the loki finale here is that
a lot of the what-if episodes are basically taken
from a lot of these different branches that you
see popping up at the end of the episode like you
have all these realities that kang was trying to
prevent with all this crazy wtf stuff happening
and we'll see some of that play out during the
marvel what if episodes the watcher played by
jeffrey wright you may recognize his voice if
he didn't see the big comic-con panel where
they announced he was playing marvel's watcher
is watching all this play out and per the rules
of his race can't really interfere like he
explains that during the trailer he's bound to not
interfere but he can't speak to them explain the
stakes to them and give them a push so to speak
so as he narrates the action watching this all
play out across the multiverse you have these
multiverse avengers coming together from across
all the episodes and even though it kind of seems
like ultron is the main villain of season one like
ultron with all the infinity stones and vision's
body it seems like good pick for main villain but
they haven't completely explained how they're
going to play that because for instance the
infinity stones only work in the original universe
that they came from so unless marvel changes that
this version of ultron would only be able to use
these infinity stones in the original reality that
he came from so what they might be doing because
they are assembling all these different characters
from different alternate universes is they might
be going for a really rick and morty twist like
rick and morty meets marvelous exiles if you're
not familiar with marvel's exiles they're a
multiverse team made up of characters from
different realities and they just travel around
to different universes solving really big problems
in each different universe during rick and morty
early on the series they introduced the concept
that sometimes the main version of rick or
sometimes other ricks as well would pack up their
junk and just permanently move to another reality
maybe because the one they were in got destroyed
or something terrible happened that they couldn't
fix or didn't want to fix like everyone getting
cronenberg we actually saw a good comparison to
this during the what if trailer it would be like
marvel zombies happening like oh crap everybody's
been turned into a zombie on this planet there's
no way we can fix this time to pack up our crap
and head to a different universe pack your that's
only going to keep them down for a little bit
morty you with squirrels morty we got a good five
minutes before they're backing up on our ass morty
we have to pack up and move to a new reality
morty so even though marvel's what if episodes
are animated it's still connected to the other
marvel movies and live action disney plus series
like loki it's just them taking advantage of all
the chaos that loki and sylvie caused unleashing
the true version of the multiverse and kevin feige
said what if we make it animated everyone get your
family guy memes ready we'll see how many times
they actually say the name of the show inside
the show itself like up see he said the thing he
called it what if if you understand animation you
also understand why they're doing this animated
because if they did action and fight scenes every
five seconds at this scale in live action it would
cost more money to make this show than they used
to make avengers infinity war in avengers end game
combined in disney's like we're not going to spend
a billion dollars making 10 episodes of television
but kevin feige made this big deal about how they
wanted every episode of what if to feel like
a big marvel movie by itself as opposed to say
like wandavision or even loki which had really big
episodes they did feel amazing but most the time
they still felt like tv shows and every once in
a while they would just get really really huge if
you're a big fan of the classic what if comic book
stories the other big change they made here is
that the series what if is meant to be serialized
episodes so all the episodes are connected in a
way that the original what if comics were not like
you see captain carter starred in world war ii in
her episode i believe that's meant to be episode
one but then you also see her show up later in the
doctor strange episode to recruit him you see
killmonger in that early iron man one episode
but then you also see him later fighting ultron's
army in wakanda you see thor get his hammer back
in the early thor movie episode then later he's
fighting ultron's army in vegas and then also
later in their big avengers episode you see them
together doing their avengers assemble moment
there are supposed to be 10 episodes in season
one they've already confirmed a while ago it will
get a season two but they didn't say when that's
going to premiere hopefully it'll be next year we
don't have to wait that long but it sounds like
they spend most of season one just going around
assembling this team across all the episodes doing
the origin stories like here are the major events
of the mcu that went down differently in these
realities and then when we get to season two
they just spend all the episodes flying around the
different universes solving problems as the team
and maybe cycling the roster every once in a while
because the other big thing is they have all the
mcu actors coming back to play their characters so
i don't expect for instance like chris hemsworth
to come back for 10 seasons of what if there were
like two or three marvel actors that didn't come
back to voice their characters everybody else
came back like robert downey jr already kind of
said he's retired as iron man so that's why he's
not coming back chris evans kind of said the same
thing retired from doing captain america but you
have people like tom holland doing the voice of
his version of spider-man when spider-man shows up
during the series in terms of the what-if versions
of the characters though showing up in live action
i think that winds up happening it won't happen
until the next big secret war style movie and
they'll be like background characters like they'll
pay off the promise of a lot of these alternate
realities but really the loki finale just teased
the concept of a secret war style movie happening
in the future like an all-out multiverse war with
many alternate universe versions of
characters battling to save their realities
all because of what kang's variants are doing
so everyone let me know in the comments if we
do start seeing some of the characters from the
what if series the alternate universe versions
showing up in live action which movie do you think
that will be and which versions of the characters
do you want to see show up in live action but
hopefully that explains what's going on and
if you were wondering yes the series is canon but
like i said you probably won't start seeing these
animated characters actually crossing over like
legit crossing over in live action to like way
way down the road in a big crossover secret war
style movie obviously a lot of what happened in
the loki finale will inform what's happening in
spiderman no way home doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness ant-man 3 quantum mania i'll talk
about that when we get some new footage for all
these upcoming movies and there's all kinds of
rumors about the spider-man no way home trailer
whenever they do decide to release that of
course i'll do a video for it everyone click
here for my loki finale alternate ending and
deleted scenes video and click here for all my
loki episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!